[Music]
okay before we go we got to do human
friends a bit yeah
what he's a human friend to paid it's a
photo we always take it's like the movie
Human Centipede where they're sewn
together mouth to anus but it's with
friends so it's special
I get the middle oh why do you want the
middle this is it your Bachelorette
weekend you've been dreaming about this
moment it's the first day of freshman
year we're gonna be swimming and dick
girl
I just got coke from The busboy life so
everyone's in Douglas I was kind of
hoping that we could make it an early
mate
it doesn't feel right yeah I don't think
so baby girl put on these [ __ ] sashes
oh my god I'm so hot baby God you so now
you got too much me
beware your face let's get a stripper
guys male or female though yeah ma'am I
think email for her fine nice to feel
special
he's dead sir oh god no no no no we're
gonna do what you wanna do I know you
get the picture you're going to which
one you're totally [ __ ] take my
picture
there was this guy in Australia who
cooked his girlfriend and ate her you I
can't cuz I am vegan by me
let's get steak be the best weekend of
our parking lot I probably have HPV now
whenever we all have each PV I don't
have HPV if you've had sex after the
year 1991 then you do have HPV oh then I
have like a [ __ ] ton of HPV clumps and
clumps of it
[Music]